all right then let's welcome travis
we'll talk about
um
effectively using open source
yeah
great always a few things
great well it's good to be here um
third talk in 24 hours so uh
uh this one is uh a topic i like and
hopefully it's a bit of a tutorial i'm
hoping that people have their laptops
and we can actually uh work through some
things get you all signed up on bin star
get you actually deploying packages and
show you what that's like and then i
have elon here who's actually the author
of anaconda and uh principal developer
of conda so uh he is going to be able to
answer any of the questions that we all
might
have uh the goal is just walk through
and kind of help help get up to speed
teach a little bit of an overview of
what kind of is what it is also relate
it to bin star how the two are connected
and what they do and how they can help
you uh so there's a couple of
presentations that i'll use actually
you're probably going to do the
presentation tomorrow right
on sunday you're giving a presentation
that's uh
specifically so i don't necessarily
yeah are you going to use uh aaron's
slides pretty much okay
so uh i have i have several talks i've
given on converse so
who here has actually used kana to build
a package raise your hand if you've done
that before excellent only two people
three four maybe other people aren't
listening uh well by the end all of you
will be able to do this because it's
very very simple uh unless it's hard
uh uh that's the thing about build is
that uh you can go from it can take you
two seconds to two weeks depending on
exactly what it is you're trying to
build uh but the nice thing is kinda
makes it really straightforward
all right so i'll give a little bit of
just kind of overview
uh
one of the concepts sort of the
opportunity is that open source e in the
software world there's just enormous
these these projected numbers of
software packages being released
actually if you watch pi
or you watch cran or cpan or any of the
or node is was horrendous it's just
exploding partly because they
you know they uh they make a single
function and make a package out of it
just throw it up there so uh but you
just have all these things just
exploding
and now how do you actually use this for
real i mean how are you going to
actually
make sure you can deploy all this
repeatedly have some mechanism to
that's great your one developer could
make it all work and have it work once
and now you're supposed to repeatedly do
that again as versions change and they
will and they do you expect that how you
supposed to maintain this it's not an
option to adopt it once and pull it all
together in a working model you have to
figure out how you can actually have
this working together
there is a fundamental tension here
right because at the course
one core software engineering principle
is the idea of separation of concerns
it's probably one of the only top three
principles which is the idea that you
want to separate out concepts and
independently
deal with them and only bring them back
together the final moment rather than
have everything kind of interconnected
but that principle leads to granular
libraries it leaves the idea well this
concept should be separated here so i
can refactor it over there and that
often leads to very deep dependencies
which has its own issue and it's often
called dll hell or dependency hell but
ultimately it's called bad package
management that's really the you know
that's people say it's dll-hell but it's
because there's no system for managing
those packages now that's not to say
there aren't issues you can arrive
there's there are issues when you when
you have a deep dependency tree there
are issues that can arise and one of the
techniques we've taken with conda is to
actually create a collection of tools
that let you
manage that complexity in a myriad of
ways it's going to have simple tools
have simple package formats simple
concepts that lets you mix and match
different ideas together in order to
manage the complexity of your life
so
here's the challenge there's different
quote unquote entry points and we see
this all the time
node users for example if you're
everything's an application so it
install everything together into one big
uh
i think go does this too they like they
don't like shared libraries no shared
libraries and go so everything's just
one big monolithic static binary
which is great if you're an application
developer you know who doesn't want to
think of i built this application it's
just an exe or it's just an rpm i hand
off to somebody fantastic
but if you want to reuse code that's
really crummy like great you build all
that stuff and now how does somebody use
your library how do you really do this
because there's different kind of entry
points
uh there's this you know the challenge
about this this tension between the it
managers who want ease of development
test deployment testing developers want
agility and easy development
i've gone to multiple organizations and
that fundamental tension exists even if
it's not identified as to why the
developers and i t people can't get
along
that happens in my organization it
happens everywhere i see there's this
like oh you're just awful you don't
understand you don't understand it's
really because there's a tension here
people the uh and i think that we can
manage this
with the right tools and with the right
systems
so
the goal is to have developers and not
just developers but what we call what i
call domain experts or subject matter
experts these are people who are
occasional developers uh business
analysts or
scientists or quants or they might be
called many things your organization but
they're the people that kind of drive
business value and they kind of need to
code a little bit throw snippets of code
together
how do they do that quickly take
advantage of latest software
developments to help them
but still
over time produce stable production
deployments how do you really manage
that uh you can't really take a full
advantage open source until you can
manage that problem
uh i have a few examples here at scipy i
won't go into too much detail about this
but basically uh anybody use sci-fi in
the room here anybody know what sci-fi
is okay so a lot of people for a long
time cypher was oh i hate sci-fi because
i can't build it and it's really because
there's a fortran compiler and most
people throughout their 4chan compiler
when they started using c
not necessarily fortunately for
fortran's still a good good little uh uh
run time executable uh
but it's basically a bunch of interfaces
to low level code so it's kind of the
epitome of packaging problems
in in how do i actually manage this
um so in fact most of my effort around
sci-fi distribution has been a packaging
problem and in fact sci-fi itself
really
was a distribution masquerading as a
library
um
so you know one of the
and the reason it was is because the
difficulty of people getting everything
installed you know multi-pack was which
preceded scipy was really a wrapping
around uh ode pack and
fft pack and quad pack which are these
netlab library for doing differential
integration
and
optimization
you pull all that together and really
those could be individual libraries and
just shipped independently and they've
been better
they didn't they didn't have
dependencies on each other but the
desire was to give one single install
one single library could bring it all
together because of the
application problem but the problem was
is doing that led to a maintenance
problem because the concept of sci-fi is
too big i mean you know
the idea that you know one to five of us
are really going to maintain all the
world's libraries
for scientific computing
it's kind of hard to believe right
there's a lot of things you can do a lot
of a lot of things you want to do and
you don't want it to be centrally
controlled but to do that you have to
have really good packaging to manage
that so made a mistake with scipy
because there was not good packaging in
python at the time and scipy became kind
of a big package a big installer that
was shipped
so
i mean i i say this stuff to try to help
people understand why is it that this
guy who was doing science is now doing
packaging for all things what you know
how did this happen
uh and you know my phd professor is
probably saying that himself i'm sure
you know
i certainly have not given him the the
the i did have a phd student graduate so
he did have a little bit of that but
um i'm now doing things entirely
different but because of the problems
found in trying to ship large and trying
to
organize large-scale software uh
projects then the other problem that
happened because of pakini was numpy
i started writing numpy in 2005. i was
teaching at byu it was a merger of new
american memory if you saw my keynote
you know some of that
so it's a it's a point in fact that the
numpy abi that means the application
binary interface has not changed
officially since 1.0 came out in 2006.
that was not a design goal that was not
something i had planned for or expected
or in fact it's still embarrassing to
see some of the code that's in there oh
i would change there's a car and there's
a car character and a struct that should
be an end but it's not because it's
never changed even though oh i'll change
that in the next release
there never was the next abi release
there'd been more releases but they all
had to have backward compatibility
backward binary compatibility and why
because numpad numpy has a c api that
other modules compile against so
matplotlib scikit learn scipy they all
compile against this cavi so if i if
numpy came out with a new abi release
all those packages would have to be
recompiled
and for for linux users that's not a big
deal great apt-get install yum install
the new versions i don't care no big
deal but for windows users and there's a
lot of windows users of the stack
they would spend days setting up their
system and now you're going to change
numpy from under them i'll have to
re-spend all those days
installing my packages again and so that
it became a victim of its own success
right all these people started using
numpy all the stacks started happening
never went no i can't possibly change
the api
that was so uh
and the reason there's no packaging if
some a good packaging solution that
existed on windows this pressure would
not have been as strong i guarantee it
so uh this has been a point of some
contention and community difficulty
actually the date time which started in
version 1.4 and actually there was some
problems and confusion about is it api
compatible isn't it went back and forth
uh it really was impossible to add new
data types to numpy without changing the
api and so you know this pressure oh we
want to add date time we want to we have
a good idea of how to do it we can't do
it because this
weird social interaction of lack that's
in it's really caused by lack of
packaging
so
the numpy stack is basically a cry for
conda it's basically cry for a
cross-platform
robust
packaging solution
and so that's what we did uh kind of
initially was said we are going to build
a packaging solution i actually have i
have a slide here uh peter put it
together because we had a at the first
pi data meeting at googleplex it was a
pi data workshop and we were at google
and uh had a chance guido came and we
talked to him about kind of our problems
in the scientific community one of them
was hey we have we have this packaging
problem the sign of the community what
is going to happen what are you all
going to do about it in in python
because we've just been waiting around
right python those expert programmers
are going to fix this for us
and uh guida said yeah um you'd fix it
yourself
uh
you know just go ahead and fix it
yourself right because i don't wait for
anybody in python to fix it
i've since learned
that while standing with uh talking with
vito at last pycon i i asked we talked
about the packaging salute story i told
him dot con i said thank you thanks for
the suggestion we did we fixed it uh he
said oh great i personally never have
any dependencies i think dependencies
are evil so
i guess that's okay when you write the
language you can just throw it in the
standard library if you have a
dependency right
but for others it's a little bit harder
uh so so in that one sentence i
understood the packaging problem in
python
uh just it has not been on his radar now
nick coughlin and others in the python
packaging authority have been doing a
lot of work to try to fix this problem
it's kind of happened in the same at the
same time that uh we you know kind of at
the same time they were doing this and
we had this story for conda and we've
kind of come up with
uh comparable solutions uh uh we're
farther along condo actually works now
for uh cross-platform
um
metadata on the server side all the
dependency information you can gather
uh it's actually the official language
that we've kind of agreed on is that
pip when you use pip
even when you use wheels and pip you are
a self-integrator so if you want to be a
self-integrator you can with pip and
wheels if they exist for your packages
conda is a integration solution just
like
rpm or homebrew or any of these other
cross-plat these these integration
solutions they give you a full install
of everything you might need
including things that aren't python so
including hdf5 or pi tables or anything
else so
we do have
uh including python itself including
python itself that's exactly right so we
can do things with conda like install
python 1.0
or python 3.0 and you can switch between
them in your environments and it's
really quite nice you can go back and
forth and install r you can install
new libraries
so we're gonna kind of get to the
concepts about how this is all possible
uh so the fundamental principles of
conda are basically that complex things
are built out of simple things
um so we want to create
our you know if you think about any
application stack these days it's
complex there's enormous numbers of
things going on but it's not built by
somebody understanding all that
complexity it's built by blocks by block
those simple things with simple
interfaces
so uh
reusable is enhanced and do one thing as
well but to deploy you got to bring
these things together so you got to have
a good packaging solution
so
these are some of the continuum
solutions
uh apologize if this looks like an
advertisement um conda is a free all
this is free so all this stuff uh is
available open source you can use it you
can fork it you can use it for your own
distributions
but there are a few words here so it can
be kind of okay what are all these names
and what does it mean
kind of in the lower right anaconda is a
single click install of a bunch of
packages beside and plus python so it's
kind of it's intended for big data
analytics so it includes all the key
numpy stack packages like numpy sci
python matplotlib bokeh numba
pandas stats models about 100 packages
everything you might need all in one
either
installer on windows or a graphical
installer on mac or a bash script on
linux
one way to get everything
it under the covers uses conda so it's
just kind of a big install of everything
with conda now some people that's a lot
of that's a lot of packages i don't want
all that i just want to use kana to get
just what i need
then mini condo what it is is basically
python plus conda it's just a it's
basically the same
roughly the same thing you get at
python.org i think we use the same
compilers they use at python.org
uh elon can check
who produces the condo package on
windows we do on windows we use exactly
the same compilers as they do to produce
the python.org binaries so it's
compatible uh but you have a python plus
conda so that you can then
kind of install anaconda in your
miniconda will give you anaconda
that's a lot of hondas
but it illustrates the point but you
don't have to install anaconda maybe you
just want to go i just want
psychic learn and everything else needed
for psychic learn so you just say con
install psychic learn and then you have
your own environment with just what you
need for scikit learn to work so it
resolves dependencies
uh it does it without going and
downloading the packaging because we'll
get to it later but there's index
information there's metadata information
it's an important distinction it's what
differentiates condo really from other
solutions
at the heart is this cross-platform
package manager called conda
it uses dependency management it uses a
sat solver or satisfiability solver to
resolve all the dependencies and then it
creates system level virtual
environments uh definitely inspired by
virtual m but more flexible than virtual
lam it doesn't do any sys site dot py
path hacking or python path hacking it's
just simply a like a ch root much closer
to ch root just make sure that it also
ensures that all the
um we well we don't insure that all the
time when we build packages we ensure
that the packages are relocatable so
that they're only dependent on binaries
and shared libraries that are relative
to the to the current environment so you
can have multiple versions of a single
package installed in the same box
so conda and then there's binstar.org
binsar.org is basically a place for you
to host your own repositories
so you can set them up yourself on your
own web server and we'll show you how to
do that in this tutorial
but bins.org is like a public place for
if you don't want to do that you can
easily put packages up there it's
completely free if you're willing to
give your packages away and have other
people see them
if you want to make private packages
then there's a small charge
all right and that's the
premium solutions
um so conda again is like a
cross-platform
macport homebrew
yum appgate there are actually some
solutions on windows i had to search
quite a bit for these but chocolatey and
impact d
so you may be interested in those
but condes basically does
the same kind of thing but across all
the platforms you don't have to learn
one system
to manage your windows different systems
to manage windows linux and
os x you just use the same system
and then with these virtual environments
that kind of creates as well these are
system level environments you have a
cross-platform system level packaging
deployment solution really it gives you
a lot of the same flexibility for if
you're just installing apps like if you
don't have to do anything with system
services a lot of people use docker for
example just
if you're using docker just to create an
app environment cond is a much lighter
weight faster approach to doing that now
obviously it doesn't do anything with
system services so if you need an ftp
server or you need to differentiate your
mail server and have that on different
system images docker is a great solution
still use it
but it just gives you another entry
point so you can really solve your
problem without necessarily going to the
more heavyweight solution
a um directory like uh yeah nfs yes is
it still better to use honda rather than
docker because i don't know uh systems
are kind of like
different
issues sometimes if you have centos 6
fedora
and if you have the same conda then some
things blow up um possibly i mean so you
can definitely set it up so it doesn't
blow up i mean all the platform is a
dependency tree back to glib c and lib m
and normally we don't we normal i mean
you you could build a whole linux
distribution with con if you wanted you
can just ship the glibc and the lib m
with conda that's that was exactly what
your machines needed
uh we
i would have to look at the use case
before i told you which i would advise i
mean specifically i don't i don't know i
mean i could see i could see both being
viable depending on the situation yeah
we'd have to talk in more detail but
just i put it out there as some people
immediately turned to something like
docker when a condo environment solution
is much lighter weight and simpler and
would work just fine but not in all
cases right obviously so
um
so what are the kind of features we'll
get into some of the details here but
just as a very high level it's got
excellent support for system level
environments like having many vms uh
lighter weight though than a real
container it's just a directory with
that with everything uh
connected
so it minimizes code copies uh it does
have this notion of of sharing but it
only shares if it can otherwise and it
shares by doing hard links or soft links
or copies based on whether it can so if
it's all in the same disk it can use
hard links if it's mounted across disks
it uses soft links and occasion it has
to actually copy
the dependency solver uses a fast
satisfiability solver that's wrapped
into python it's basically uh it's it's
more than a satisfiability solver it
uses a constrained
it's like a mixed integer programming
problem that gets solved uh
and it's very helpful
you can have a situation where it might
take a really long time if you have no
satisfiable solution
but that can be managed by changing your
it can actually manage by changing your
channels like how many repositories
you're looking at if your repository
grows really really big with tens of
thousands of packages and it has to find
all the possibilities that can take a
little bit of time a lot of times people
will just just shrink their channels and
then have a bunch of them differently
we'll explain that a little more detail
now the format is one of my favorite
features of conda it is a simple format
it's just a tarball with metadata so
it's
i'll talk about the more detail but
that's a really great feature
the metadata is then extracted and
hosted on the server separately from the
binary package therefore conda can
actually do a metadata a static analysis
of dependencies prior to downloading
anything installing things which is one
of its big features
it's very easy to create multiple
channels which are basically directories
of condo packages to look at so you can
have a server and you can have lots of
directories with different channels and
on the client they can decide which ones
they want and they're just repositories
just places to differentiate partition
basically your binary packages
user installable no root is needed and
you can still you can still obviously
use tools like pip kana just gives you a
python environment and pip still works
in that python environment just as it
does before virtual them should also
still work but occasionally we encounter
people with with the occasionally issues
arise largely because of path sometimes
people set their python path sometimes
people
there's just so many different
configuration states that are out there
that occasionally
i've seen issues arise
when we identify them we fix them but
but sometimes they're not really bugs as
they are just misconfigurations
all right so here's a simple example
first of all
uh everybody should get con if you don't
have conda go to continuum.io downloads
and or else actually don't go to
anaconda download it let's just go to
mini conda and download
that so where do we go
we go to conde.paiday.org
and uh this is lacy explains conda it's
a
the pilot organization
you go down here and you can get
mini conda
for all these platforms so you can just
click on the one that correspond to your
platform
and install it
if you happen to end up at the downloads
page
of
continuum this is the place you can go
to just download the package without
inserting basically on our store on our
site you know this difference of if
people come to the store and that's how
they find anaconda then they have to
give us their email address before we
give them the place where they go to
download
but if you go directly to this link then
you don't have to do that you can just
click on the button and w get it so
that's intentional
basically it's sort of a it's a
trade-off it's a fight we have with the
marketing guys right um
i want people to get it quickly but you
know they want to be able to get some
information and try to help uh push
things farther but if you end up here
you can there is a little message down
here that tells you you can download
mini conda
it's go it's great to get go ahead and
get anaconda if you don't have anything
on your system so far but a lot of times
if you're just wanting to get started
minicom is a lot less uh
stuff i should turn off my flow docs so
you don't have to have a conversation
with the entire company while we're
talking
all right um
so once you have it then you basically
can
a lot of times
uh you know we'll say con update on
update condo but it really hasn't
changed much so for a while
uh one of the things we did was factor
out the build for example condo build
sometimes changes more often
as a separate package
so i don't think that's changed recently
however as well
so just to make sure you have the latest
it's useful to kind of update the
packages and then just install something
uh we're first going to create an
environment though and install just
python and pip into that packet into
that
directory
so first i'm going to see if i have
environments i probably already have a
test environment
so i'm going to
remove
let's see is it dash dash all or just
all
and
that basically gets rid of all the
packages the environment removes it
um i i sometimes i actually just delete
the directory
right
that's okay too right just making sure a
lot of times i just grow the directory
and blow it away because ultimately a
package an environment is just a
directory and it's usually stored if you
hit condo info you'll see
basically where your con install what's
what's what's present
there's a root environment
and it sees if it's writable or not
because you can have a root environment
that's on a read-only disk and then
maybe you have your own place that's not
read-only and and so when you install
packages they have to go there so you
have this kind of
system level route and then you are
installing over here
in a separate package cache
the environment directory is just under
there under the ms directory now these
are all named environments you can put
an environment anywhere on the file
system you want
but named environments have a little
more flexibility they
they're easier to type easier to spell
some things work better with named
environments as well
but you can if you want just put an
environment on any any path you like
the challenge is then you may not be
able to see it if you list all your
environments condo may not find that
particular environment it just looks in
the named environments
so if i go there to anaconda ms
you can see there's all my direct all my
environments so i can remove
my pi 3k environment
right and that actually goes and deletes
a bunch of files
and comes back and then kind of list
actually
actually conda info dash e
shows me my
pi 3k is gone
so that's also an approach
to getting rid of environments
so i got rid of the test so i could i
could re i could rebuild one
so um
it's going off and
unlinking a bunch of files
so going back to home directory i'm
going to kind of create
and test and then i'm going to tell it i
want python and i want pip
now
i just said python and so by default it
gives me the python that is
the root
is that correct it gives me the python
that conda is built with i guess or is
running under so because i'm running a
2.7 version of conda
when i just say python it gives me
python 2.7 now if you've downloaded mini
conda or anaconda for 3.3 3.4 then when
you say conda create and say python
it'll give you a python 3 environment
okay so here's a so it tells me this is
the plan
it
it doesn't actually uh download anything
because all those packs have been
previously downloaded and stored in the
cache and so it just links a new
environment for me very very quickly
so that's ready to go and then all i
need to do to run python out of that
environment is actually go to the path
that i've just created and there's it's
like a user path there's a bin directory
there's a lib directory it's sort of
it's it's like a
a high-level directory it's a prefix
directory for all the all of the
packages so i can go there directly and
type python and now i'm running that
version of python that's and it works
if i import sys
sys.path you can see that it has that
environment
uh and test lib that's where all that
it's going to get all its packages from
now quite often people don't do that
they'll instead use this sort of source
activate concept and source activate
python or test
and it'll
for it works for bash i don't think i
think it only works for bash presently
right if you use fish or z shell or
other c shell
then please
commit a patch to help us support those
shells with our source activate command
it'd be awesome
so in test now you can run python and
it'll pick up that python it just adds
to the path is all it does when you do
source activate
okay so that's great now i have a
separate place i can test i can do
something like install scikit learn
into that packet into that directory now
scikit-learn is going to have a few more
packages to look at
so it tells me oh i need to install
numpy and scipy and scikit-learn i
didn't have any any specific versions
and so i picked the latest version
of each that were compatible
and there we go and if i say condo list
that'll tell me the packages that are
installed
uh numpy open ssl python pip
i can still pip install into this what
do i want to pip install perhaps
wheel
why not
there we go so now i have wheel
installed in my environment now condo's
not managing that i can't condo remove
wheel i have to pip and put uninstall
wheel but that's fine
and if i say condo list it will show me
wheel and tell me that it's actually pip
that installed that
so see
any questions so far oh one if you're on
windows it's not source activate test
it's activate test i don't think that
actually works in powershell i think it
just works in the command prompt so
that's one source of some questions just
say activate and then it activates that
directory as the path
okay any questions on that
now
of course that's not as interesting as
potentially
let's get out of this
source deactivate and that get get out
of this guy
deactivate
now i want to actually conduct create a
python 3 environment because my friends
tell me that python 3 is all the rage
everybody's using python 3. if you're
not you're somehow not hip so but i'm ah
but i've got to have all this software
run on python 2 what am i going to do
just make an environment with python 3k
i'm going to name it pi 3k and i'm going
to install python but say equal to
python 3.3 remember conda is a package
manager that's a system level package
manager so i can install python as well
as install anything
uh and into python 3.3 i'm also going to
install scikit-learn which i think i can
still do
right
i think recently we made that possible
so it's going to go out
find out what needs to happen ah it's
actually going to go download some
things because i don't have scikit-learn
for python 3.3 yet on my machine so it's
going to go out download those things
and then link
all the rest now i can give to the conda
command a dash y or dash dash yes to
avoid that prompt if i'd like if you're
doing a script you don't want to have
hit hit pause
so it goes out downloads installs
it basically extracting a package means
it's unzipping
that condo package itself is just a tarp
it's a b zip tarball
so the first step is to go into the
package cache and unturn it or unzip it
and then turn it and then
it just sits there and when i make an
environment it puts hard links to the
place to the to the package cache where
it lives in fact if files if operating
systems had union file systems that work
better
you could imagine a condo environment
would simply be a union file system of
the packages that it consists of
that's all it would be you just kind of
merge all those paths together and you'd
have your single directory that would be
your your your installation
uh it's actually uh it makes me want uh
union file systems but we we kind of we
fake them with hard links and soft links
basically and copies if ultimately
necessary
okay so now i can
source activate
pi 3k
and then when i type python i have
python 3.3 and i can play with it and
it's only got it it's not affecting my
other installation so i can import
scikit-learn and have a type error
nice
apparently we have a problem with our
scikit-learn 2.3 vlan
ah there we go thank you
uh source
deactivate
and
you're right uh 3.4
it already exists so we'll call it 3 4k
it has to download
why does that download i guess numpy
again
oh and now it's actually downloading
python 3.4 because it's the first time
i've ever created a python 3.4
environment in my system
excellent and scikit-learn
and scipy
0.14
fortunately the internet is pretty fast
here
so far um
so far unless everybody here is
downloading at the same time yes
question
it shouldn't because this really
installs in its own isolated directory
so unless you install anaconda in a
place where brew is already located then
it shouldn't now it should be fine now
there are potential problems if you like
have ld library paths set or you have
some of these other environment
variables set while you're building or
compiling that are actually linking up
against your brew libraries
that could create some issues
but none of this install will be a
problem it'll always just install into
that separate isolated location that you
can you can just go blow away if you're
done with it you can go into that
directory and just remove it all
and you haven't touched your your uh
environments
the install of anaconda doesn't change
anything it asks you if you want to
change your path
that's all it asks you it asks and what
it means is just inserts the directory
it just installed anaconda at the top of
your path you don't have to do that but
we do that now by default i think on
linux do we still do that by we don't do
that on a default on linux do we
i know we do it by default on windows
and mac
um because of uh you know that's sort of
what people expect when they install a
distribution they expect that when you
run python they'll get that distribution
now but
um
all right now let's see if my test will
work
not there it won't
running python 3.4 look at that
nope
still a problem
oh i know why
ah look at this
i have a dot no no no i have a types
i have a really stupid
file here
my in my directory where i'm importing
this is what this is one of those
you know arcane errors you see
occasionally
that's right
and that's a perfect you're right this
happens quite often on the main list
gets excoriated elon you broke this and
it's like no it was me
it uh it's just it's the kind of things
that can happen right so that's a pretty
good example
uh and now
uh
so
one once uh i use con all the time and
it's just it makes my life so much
easier because i can test i can install
i can create i can
anything i want to do with the packages
that are there
so
any questions so far i want to go talk a
little bit about kind of we've seen a
little bit of the root directory
installation how it's laid out i showed
you the root directory that's the
anaconda directory and we can kind of
see just a few more of these
if i go to my anaconda directory this is
the root directory you can see there's
quite a few packages here but really the
important directories here what the
important things
are lib
it's basically a root directory on its
own
so it's basically got a bin a lib it's
like a when i
uh
it's got a bin directory it's got a
python directory that's my root python
that's the python that actually conda
itself uses so if i look in that bin
directory that's where
conda also lives
conda is only ever in one that one
important thing about condos is only in
ever the root directory so it actually
does show up in your other environments
but it's just pointing back to the same
conda in your root directory you can
never only have one conda command in an
anaconda distribution
uh you could create install miniconda
again in a separate like you could
install any kind of 3.3 or 3.4 in a
separate directory somewhere else in
your file system then you'd have another
conda command
but that's the only way to get a
different you can't install conda itself
into another root directory i think are
there other packages like that i think
it's just condo it might be maybe condo
build or anything that uses conda
kind of build also there's just a few
like that that cannot that
can't be installed
but basically you have the pat the
environment director we talked about
then there's this also this pkgs
directory that's the package cache it's
the place where packages go to be
untired if i go in there you can see
basically there's all the packages i've
downloaded and their
untarred cells basically
now actually if you've used anaconda for
a while that directory might get filled
up pretty quickly right because
i download packages i untar them then i
link them into directories and after a
while i might delete directories unlink
them remove environments these packages
still stay in the cache
so
how do i
clean that up elon
so well that gives a help right
so he's kind of teaching me to fish
right
condo clean dash h it tells it tells you
uh tarballs
or packages
right
right so packages that'll get rid of
unused uh cash packages there is a there
is a warning here because it doesn't
actually check for sim link packages
so if you do have a system my system
doesn't have simulink packages because i
only have a single disk but if you're on
a
multi-mounted system it's possible and
you have environments directories that
are um on a separate disk because you
can you can have multiple package caches
you have multiple environment
directories if you separate them on
multiple disks you can have a situation
where you have sim links and the clean
will not check
so it says oh i'm going to get you know
have another half of
490 megabytes back so it goes through
and removes all those unused tarballs
and all the uh unused directories oh
look at that a gigabyte of free space
so these are all the packages that
aren't used in any uh environment
presently
according to the hard link
right there's no hard links to them
so that's that's one way you can clean
up your system if you kind of over time
you have you want to observe a little
disk
customly space languages
stuff that you use
oh yeah same thing
same
no no oh i see
if that's the only place you have them
yes
if so it's not a good idea to put your
uh built condom packages in a packaged
cache uh because it might get removed
usually those are put in a separate
directory like a repository directory
you move them to a channel as another
name really for a directory
that is used as a place to store kind of
packages
so
you know right there we can see uh and
we'll see in a second what a condo
package is
it's very simple collection of kind of
how to
how to deal with a with a binary
artifact uh cotton packages can contain
any kind of binary artifact they're just
simply a tarball of stuff that will get
installed on your system
um let's look take a look at it and kind
of what kind of packages are
there
tar.bz2 there is a package name
and then there's a if you kind of look
at it from this way you can see it's
it's a uniform but this package name can
contain
its
its lowercase letters or
numbers uh in all but the second all
with the first
and then dashes as well could be in the
package name
and then you have a dash and you have
the version number
and that can also that can contain
letters it can contain kind of whatever
your version number specification is but
i you know i really advise kind of the
major minor micro
concept or version numbers possibly an
rc1
or an alph an a for an alpha you can put
that on the version number now that's
really all that that conda uses except
possibly this build number here
this build string is
is just a tag to kind of help you
remember what it is basically this is
for pi270 but otherwise it's not really
used by conda
other than this final zero which is the
build number
and it will sometimes use that build
number to differentiate between equal
versions but one is a build number one
versus build number two the build number
is actually in the metadata so
conda itself doesn't look at this string
at all yeah thank you
thank you this this build string is
completely ignored
and the metadata is what helps uh
use it
all right so then if you look inside
of an unzipped condo package
i think it's worthwhile going into let's
say
tornado
right and you can see
this info directory which is the
metadata directory all content packages
have an info directory so the astute
observer will recognize that if your
particular package needs an info
directory
we actually have a problem uh
sort of i mean not just
because there's only a few files that
info directory so if you're a faker
package as an info directory with those
we might have a problem so far we've
been okay with every package we've had
we've never had a problem
but there does exist a small potential
problem there
but it just has lib and inside lib
you'll have lib python 27 side packages
tornado
right so it's kind of that
part of the tree or the file system tree
where how that gets installed
and that's that's what's in so tornado's
not that interesting it's just got one
single uh directory in site packages but
if we go to something a little more
interesting like
i don't know let's see
like python very good
python 3.4.1
we'll see it has several of these
top-level directories that's been it has
an inside bin you'll see 2-3 python idle
you'll see a lot of the binaries that
are installed in
include
you'll see the python 3.4 m interesting
you'll see an info directory that's that
we'll come back to that later that's the
metadata you'll see the live which has
the python 3 4 and the dynamic library
and the share
which has the man pages
so
it basically contains whatever
the make config or whatever the build
packages had now in windows you'll see a
slightly different layout you have some
of those same directories but instead of
being at scripts and i think there's
other directories that are slightly
different as well but it's just exactly
what would be installed when that
package got
installed by whatever installer was used
so an environment then is just a union
of those paths that's it
so that's uh and that
it's a very simple concept and it lets
you really handle any kind of package
now there is this info directory is not
included in that union that info
directory is just the metadata for the
for the package and it contains it only
has to contain two files i think uh
there's others that it can contain but
it only has to contain two one is the
files directory or the files sorry the
files
file files file
the files collection of bytes that
contains
all the files that are that are
installed into all these other
directories and then this index.json
file which has metadata for the package
so that's an interesting one to look at
if we go to python 3.4.1 look at its
info directory you'll see it has other
things but if we look at the files you
can see it's just a
manifest of all the files that that are
installed so it can be tracked so you
can know if you have an environment you
can actually see well what
if i have an environment that i start
pip installing or make configuring into
that environment which you can do you
can always tell what came from condom
what didn't everything the things that
are tracked are there
it also has this index.json file which
is just a js javascript object notation
these are the
the metadata that's stored on the server
outside of the package it's got things
like the architecture the build number
uh the version number the dependencies
most importantly so you can see this
depends on these packages
and
the license the name
and requires
what's the difference between requires
and depends
thank you
okay so hide requires you don't see that
it just depends
okay
okay
the condom program only looks it depends
um so that's how it gets its dependency
tree and how it resolves exactly what
else needs to be installed now remember
this happens
as we'll see later this is all brought
together onto the server side
uh so environments i like to use this we
all know namespaces are one honking
great idea let's use more of those right
environments are really a lot like
namespaces right they're a place to kind
of do things independently of other
things you're doing on your system
and they're really a great idea once you
start using them as we all see many
people use virtual lam and they kind of
explode once you start using it because
it's really useful i can have multiple
things installed at the same time and
deal with them independently
now when you start doing system level
environments like conda allows then you
do things like i can test python 2627
3.3 on this with the same system i don't
have to install
separate versions of python
i can do it for development i can try
new packages just for the heck of it
inside of it in a clean environment and
not mess up my other house environment i
can separate deployed apps with
different dependency needs
very easily on my running system
reproducing someone's work is something
very important to us when you say here's
my analysis great and really at the
heart of why we did conduct because
somebody wants to do here's a data
dependency it's a complex workflow it's
got all these dependencies how do you
really produce that you can't reproduce
it unless you get all the dependencies
they also have
and so be able to wrap that up and then
send it over to somebody really helps
with reproducibility
so these environments the principle is
they're easy to make and easy to throw
away
so no more do you have to worry about oh
i'm gonna mess up my environment oh i'll
just throw it away and make a new one
it's okay you haven't hurt yourself i
mean you know that concept of it's okay
to make a mistake just you can make
these very easily you can rebuild them
because all the data is still stored in
the package cache so you just it's just
a matter of recreating hard links uh
is yes versioning stuff is it a good
idea to conversion uh environments
conda environments actually already have
their own revision numbers if you do
conda list dash dash
revisions
uh i think dash dash ref is is enough to
type then
you you see all the uh like
things that were done to that
environment
yeah you can say conda install and then
ref and then the number
there's a way to serialize that to a
text file that you can exchange
so that other people can install your
environment well you can go back to that
revision and then output all your files
in the environment
with the conda list e option and just
put it to a file
requirements.txt
and then
conda install with f
that file
so i'm going back to scifi
0.3
and condoles-r now i can see i have a
revision2
and you said i can go to conda install
how do i go back to the revision one
ah there we go yep okay
revision just a version one like that
there you go
now what happens when i do conda list
ah it shows me that i went back
i just wondered if it would throw away
or you know exactly what kind of logic
you'd put in there but usually that's
good you do the right things
so uh now what he's talking about i can
always
make a um that less dash e basically
makes a
a an output and even tells you what you
can do with it you create an environment
using this output and much like a
requirements file
create
name environment and give it the file
this file will recreate that environment
for somebody else you can basically just
send that over
we
there is support for the
requirements.txt file maybe you can
comment on that a little bit
yeah i mean this this file um
is basically the
same format
as the
requirements.txt file that
pip uses
except
we have a more strict
naming of exactly what packages and
build numbers it uses but
it also can understand the
requirements.txt
files
however the problem is always that it's
platform dependent that's also why in
the output here it says platform os x64
and if you give that to a friend who's
on linux some
things might be a little bit different
it might not work
right
okay so we're running out of time i
wanted to make sure we got to building
new packages so you can see what you can
do with packages there's a lot of
options to make environments create them
but you're going to encounter a
situation there's four thousand packages
on pi api we have about i don't know 200
220 230
uh condo packages
in our
tested repositories now on bin star we
have several others so if you want to
build a new package we um well basically
you just have to recreate
a package is just simply a tarball of
the binary you want so you can do it
manually if you want you can just go and
buy hook or buy crook create that binary
collection of files and go zip it up or
tar it up and put a bz2 on it uh make
sure the metadata is in there create
that files the index.json file and
you're good so you can do all that
manually and it'll work just fine you
don't have to use any tool
and i've done that before actually uh
especially for some really hard to build
things where i can only grab a binary
and then just
get it and get it involved get it like
wx python was one for example
uh
but the other option and the better
option the more reproducible option if
you really want to actually get do it
again is to create a recipe
and a recipe is a simple thing it just
has metadata about uh the information
for the file
and uh the easiest way to see a recipe i
think is to build one from pipi so let's
who has a package they want a pipi
package they want to make a condo
package out of
anybody have anything they want to do
what do you got
uh
what
is it a big binary that i can't build
yeah okay
pi q
q p o p y q p
o
that one
that one
wow what does that do
well we'll see what happens
um so basically it goes to pipei grabs
it
um
interesting
didn't like it
no module named numpy
oh i'm in pi 3 4.
it shouldn't be there
unknown for license
it didn't like no numpy hmm
well we can do the other approach
we might have the same problem though
looks like it's having trouble
the other approach is do condo pip build
what kind of pit build does is go grab
the package and try to pip install it
well if it doesn't list everything it
tries to actually execute it in a test
test location
the challenge of course is the
dependencies in the python world is all
is not descriptive it's programmatic
which is a big mistake that was them
it's duct typing of dependencies exactly
which means you're never going to really
have a system that's that's very robust
i think the problem here is that the
setup py tries to import numpy yes and
that test environment where the setup py
is executed
basically only to read
the metadata inside it that the
environment doesn't have numpy yeah
that's exactly right
so that setup.py is a little bit uh
now the question is does it actually
create it doesn't because it doesn't get
enough information to build that
to build that setup.py
it doesn't get enough from enough
dependency information to build the
recipe and so it fails
so this is one where you have to do a
manual
but you knew that didn't you
uh great
uh
uh that's actually an interesting thing
i mean we could potentially put more
robust checking in the skeleton
to at least try to
um ignore that error and come up with
basically come up with a recipe even if
it's not perfect so then you could try
to modify the recipe
um
normally if you have something that
doesn't have
let's see kinda skeleton pipei
oh let's just go to pipei and see what's
new
i always like going there
46 000
limits
there we go
limit 0.6.1
let's see what happens
also failed because it requires scipy
and it checks for that in the import
let's see there we go
yeah i know the problem is condos
skeleton is trying to
it creates a another environment with
when in which to run the setup to fake
run the setup.py
right
uh assuming that it's not going to be
checking for all the installs to be
there
but uh
so
any suggestions elon
i'm so released today it was crossroads
i have no idea what it does
you just want me to try it huh
but it does illustrate some of the
challenges with setup.py files
i think there is a pattern of people
actually putting sdis up
so that that worked uh because if you
look
that creates a directory called
crossroad which is a recipe a recipe is
just a directory and a directory that
has a meta.yaml file and then
build.shbld.bat
two separate
one is for os for posix systems and
build.bat for
windows systems if you look at build.sh
it's usually very simple it does python
setup. set up a pi install
and then
bld.bat is the same thing
but for windows it has a little bit more
sort of different spelling
so look at the meta yaml file you can
see the packages crossroad the version
um the source that's gonna is
crossroad.tar.gz
that's the file name the url it's
sitting at the md5
any patches that should be there
uh
the build
you there's here's some options you can
change preserve egg directory true or if
not it won't try to preserve an act
directory
requirements this just needs python to
build and python to run
then it tries to determine some tests so
it'll import crossroad as the test when
it's finished
okay so
uh once you have that recipe you can
kind of build crossroad
oh that's right
that's right
i
am usually in the directory above it
because you've just usually just built
it
and what condo build does is it creates
a new environment to build in
installs only the expected dependencies
and install and then and then it runs
install
and then it got an error an expected
keyword for os make deers
does it not work for python 2
so you can
build it under python 3 4
set
conda underscore oh here we go
typical python relying on python 3 or
12.
so look at that let's try that
a typical it sounds like a little
politics there okay
uh what are you saying just at the front
type uh conda underscore py equals three
four uh
no dot
just
three four
and then that will actually try to build
it with conduit with python34 in the
build directory
ah mandatory building dependency you'll
probably find it in python 3 docutils
package so that's a dependency that the
it didn't pick up
so
rs t2 man
it says it's just a build dependency
so this is the example of
trying to make sure you have all the
dependencies correctly
established
now that's the challenge i mean
one of the reasons condo is so nice to
use the installation tool is because the
dependencies are all managed
right you don't have to go fiddling and
figuring it out later so you can't find
that one
i have to make a recipe for it that's
right exactly
so
yep this is the part this is the pattern
sometimes when you find packages you can
install
and it's not called that
does docutiles have it
rst
it's not a oh mandatory building
dependency python three docutails
package okay
well
but we already have dr tilts
so i just maybe had the it just looks
for that depend not not the package but
just looks for the
rst2 man is a command yep
right doc utils
and that's you think that's available
well
it's available
so it's going to grab it
i haven't downloaded it yet
can't find it
not there
okay
so
actually i'll keep working on this but
after it says python 3 there struck
utils
i know is that something different
maybe
is it called that
i don't know but anyway we'll have to
uh we're in a time so but that is the
process you basically have to build a
recipe build a condo package condo pip
build it use a slightly different
approach so it um you don't get a recipe
it just does it tries to do the
dependency analysis and it doesn't
always work
if there are problems like that where it
can't find the right if it doesn't pick
up the dependencies from the setup.py if
they're somehow
either it can't run the setup to py
because it's something there's there's
needs before it knows about them then it
might fail but conor pitbull just does a
pip install and then uh there's a condo
package at the end there's also another
tool
called
condo package
that i've used in the past as well
condo package
dash u
kind of package will basically take
everything that's in a con environment
and make a condo package out of the
untracked files that's what kind of
package dash u does so you could for
example create your kind of package and
i could just pip install into my uh
package my directory and then
conda package the result so
for
what was it pi p b q
what's it called
pi cube pbo
i could just do this
uh and
the problem with this is if this install
it starts to download a whole bunch of
other dependencies then i'll get a whole
bunch of things
yeah let's see
qpbo
didn't like that either
okay
i need something else uh no downloads of
satisfy no distribution anyway i can
this is what i've done in the past is
just instant make install into my con
environment and then conda package dash
u
will show me the un untracked files
these are all the files in my conduct my
current package that are not tracked by
packet by conda
so right now there's a whole bunch of
other little things right
these are things i've installed in my
root directory without using condom con
install
so
usually i don't necessarily want to
install those so i might want a condo
package
h
and
r will reset all the untracked files
it'll basically give me a clean
environment and so everything is
uninstalled then i might do the things i
want to do make install pip install
whatever to get the packages i want and
then condo package dash i give it the
package name and the package version
number and then that builds for me a
package name tarball that i can then
upload as well so that's another way to
build a condo package just do the work
necessary to alter your current
environment to be
and then the diff of everything that's
there besides what's on track you can
make a package out of it so that's kind
of a
uh
hand way you know if that's the only way
you can do it sometimes that's an easy
way to get started all right i think
we're way out of time so
um but i'll stay here and help anybody
who wants to work through some of these
issues i actually find it quite fun to
make packages crazily enough you go to
my bin star you'll see that i have 2 000
packages available
no i did not do them manually
i wrote a little script that went
through and did conda pip build on
everything
in pipi
and it got about a third of them a third
of the packages on pi pi
i can't say they're all they're all
there so binstar is simply a place for
you to host your own packages it's
currently available you just go in go to
binstar.org sign up for an account
uh you can have as many you can have
different channels and the way you put
uh packages in channels is you go to
your
package
and you basically tag it
and you can also do this from the
command line binstar client
so
here's my files i can basically take
this file and i can add it to a
different channel
right so that's now in the new channel
and i've changed
uh
i've changed my
packages
let's see
i need to go to conda bin star
how do i get back that that that uh
that view
look at my channels view
uh do you don't know elon are you
yeah
he's not here but
uh i just headed up let's see uh if i
search packages
uh the dashboard is probably it there
you go thank you i keep thinking about
something else
yeah that's it the dashboard then i have
a new channel and i can see that it has
my package in it that i've just i just
put there
so you can basically add channels you
can create channels of just collections
of packages and channels are then
used by by uh
conda
you can add them to your condrc file
as just simple simply directories
when you go to a bin star there's a
there's a there's my default channel
kind of bin star if i want to add things
to a different channel
you can see that
i actually don't have to have this whole
i don't have to have this whole piece i
can just say dash c travis channel slash
new
and put that in
and i can install
from only that package only that channel
so this is an easy way for you to build
channels tell people to install from
them you can have your own sort of
directories that you are
you can have your
distribution your package you built
send someone an email or send them a
link and say con install from this place
you know they're gonna get exactly what
you ship them so it's an easy way for
you to build packages ship them around
anybody you like
now you can mimic bin star on your own
pack on your own box simply by running
conda index
on any
file you want
honda index
i don't have the con index in this uh
package
but i did
basically i
uh i copied the tar.vz files to a
directory i run cond index on that
directory and now that is a channel
so that's how i make a channel
uh i could just simply have a bunch of
tar.busy files that i make and they are
installed on my file system i move them
to a common directory and in that common
directory i say conda index
and
then i have then i have to serve them
somehow and i can either serve them via
the file url to another person on the
machine that can see that directory if
that directory is exposed to them or if
it's not then i have to create a web
service so i have to put a http simple
http server that serves that directory
and then others can see that and i can
give that to them as url it's really
really simple to build your own kind of
repositories and ship them around
so
that's a story for another day
i'll take any last questions you might
have
yeah
and so when i want to deploy some
uh for example i've developed something
under linux have some environment and an
application everything is complete
is there already in recommended way how
to deploy to windows users without
having
anything installed so far or what is
would you advise them to install some
mini conda and then
or what what is the preferred way right
right right so you are on linux you
build a system now does your is it just
python scripts does have any yeah it's
python from numpy scipy but it's also
available for right so it's just it's
just python
on top so you can actually there's a
command called conda convert
and kana convert will take your python
only file on linux and make a version
for it on windows and mac and as well
because it's just a map of file and
remapping right there's no actual
binaries has to change just you have to
rename files so chrono convert will take
your package make it on uh available for
windows you can upload it to binstar so
my recommendation is to
actually there's uh
something called the anaconda launcher
when somebody installs anaconda they get
the launcher and the launcher
is looking for special metadata in condo
package the repository is pointing to
and that special metadata is a
icon and an entry point so if your condo
package has an icon or an entry point
it'll show up
as a as an application to be installed
on a user's desktop who has anaconda
okay so that's my recommended way to do
it because it's a way you can quickly
sort of you have just made an app for
them to install by putting
an icon an entry point in your condo
package
and sticking it in a repository they
pointed their launcher to okay yeah fine
thanks yeah so that's that's my
recommended approach uh the launcher is
you can see it on the mac too but uh it
takes a little bit of effort there is
some documentation on that entry point
nikon but it needs to be improved and
we're actually the launcher is going
undergoing some some improvements it's
uh and hopefully will come out it should
come out in october in a much improved
state
all right
all right thank you let's uh thank
travis for this nice overview
you